[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's the former NFL quarterback led the
Eagles to the NFC championship and uh
and a Super Bowl and uh I think he
finished third in the MVP race in 1980
Jaws Ron Jaworski joining us you
finished third in the MVP race 1980.
that is correct in uh Brian Sipe did win
the uh MVP award in 1981 and Earl
Campbell was second and I finished third
hmm were you bitter bad not bad were you
bitter at all no not at all I want a few
other Awards the uh Maxwell award as a
player of the year the Dunlop award is
the professional athlete of the year so
you know the only the only thing is we
didn't win the Super Bowl and that's
what it's all about I I I I get a little
bit perturbed sometimes when people talk
about all these individual Awards and
I'm just a huge believer football is the
consummate Team game and I don't worry
about a you know who's winning MVP after
week eight you know who's who's the MVP
after the Super Bowl to me that's the
most important thing to as you see I got
that Vince Lombardi trophy behind me
that's what it's all about being the
world champion and when Philadelphia won
the Super Bowl in Minnesota and we had
you on the next day yeah
you're pretty emotional
well I live in this town I know how
important it was for the people in this
town to finally get to you know to be a
world champion there's been some
setbacks along the way and I you know
being a part of this city for as long as
I have been part of the eagle
organization I was a I was on the
committee that hired Doug Peterson Howie
Roseman Jeffrey Laurie and Don swalinski
uh brought me onto that even you know I
was through the through the whole
interview process with assistant coaches
and former head coaches and you know we
made that decision I still remember it
very well and we're at Jeffrey Laurie's
house the owner of the Eagles and we
took a picture uh we took a picture of
the group we said all right if we win
the Super Bowl we all get a ring
you know that was the most important
thing we covered the ring first and uh
there's my replica Super Bowl trophy so
uh it was it was great to be a part of
it and this City's on fire right now
it's a really good football team in
Philadelphia any chance Hertz plays this
weekend against the Cowboys
I would say zero uh but that's me I'm
not the doctor
um I had a broken shoulder I remember it
out of all plays Dan uh the opening of
the 1976 season now I'm going way back
I'm with the Los Angeles Rams we open up
at Fulton County Stadium in Atlanta and
on a quarterback sneak I jump over the
top Tommy Nobis hits me at the peak of
my jump drives me to the ground and much
like Jalen hurts got hurt this week you
know that that shoulder hits the ground
you know you got a 250 pound guy falling
on top of you and that's what happens in
injuries happen that way so I was out
six weeks right but I did have a slight
fracture
um Jalen is one tough dude man he is
having a you know he's having a a MVP
type season uh to me he would have been
the leader now it's probably going to
diminish that but the main thing is you
know be healthy going into the playoffs
and you got Gardner minshu who I think
is extremely talented uh talented enough
to be a starter in the league do you
take that much of a what changes with
minshu there against the Cowboys well
the diversity of the offense the the one
thing that the Eagles have done is it
created this this kind of a High Hybrid
New Wave style of offense the the basic
mechanics of a true NFL passing game and
the Hertz has improved tremendously you
got great wide receivers and AJ Brown
Devonte Smith and Dallas God will be
back this week so there's a plethora of
weapons to throw to but don't forget
that offensive line you know that the
best offensive line of football so you
know the Eagles can throw the ball with
anyone they can run the ball with anyone
they can attack you side under side line
what they will lose with Gardner mincher
is going to be an ability to run those
Zone reads and the rpos and all those
things that Jalen hurts have become so
proficient at
how good is Dallas
by the pause you're probably you're
probably wondering you know I actually I
actually predicted Jacksonville to beat
Dallas this week now probably one of the
few guys that that made that prediction
I made it publicly I do the Eagles
pregame show uh for NBC uh locally and I
made that prediction because you know
there was so much Micah Parsons talk
last week I said you know Dallas Cowboys
better worry about the Jacksonville
Jaguars not the big upcoming Christmas
Eve game against the Philadelphia Eagles
and you know they were the ones that
lost focus on that game not the
Philadelphia Eagles get I'm a big
believer Dan and you know you you and I
work together so many times one play one
game at a time you start looking down
the road that's when you find yourself
in trouble and Dallas Cowboys were not
focused against the Jacksonville Jaguars
I kind of sensed that prior to the week
I look at the tape they're not a great
football team they're a good football
team but they're gonna have to play much
better on both sides of the ball if
they're gonna you know obviously their
playoff team you got to get in the
playoffs playing good football they are
not playing Dallas Cowboy good football
right now how come how much confidence
would you have in Dak Prescott
you know I've he's incredibly talented
guy
um but I've always had him as a top 10
guy I mean it seems like the last five
or six years I felt he's in that top 10
but he hasn't crept up near the top you
know is he getting the top three the top
four the top five there's always a
blemish in this game but what is he
missing though Jaws I I don't know I I
really don't know Dan because I'm not
there every day uh and and you know when
you're around a guy every day you kind
of get a feel for what what the
strengths of weaknesses are I can look
at some mechanical things and say Hey
you know erratic throwing not consistent
accuracy and you can blame it to
improper mechanics things like that also
doesn't have a real good not a great
receiving core you know you know if you
say look at look at Jalen hurts and the
receiving Corey has in Philadelphia wow
what a difference yeah you know there's
cd-lam and there's CD Lam and there's CD
lamb you know there's really no one that
scares you outside of CD lamb
take him away Jayden and also you got uh
a quarterback that becomes somewhat
average
help me understand the line of scrimmage
with Terry McLaurin and asking the
official if I'm good
and then having some kind of
communication and then that official
throws the flag for an illegal formation
what did you see on that play
Dan we've seen it I came in the league
as a player in 1973 and I can remember
the the Jack Snows of the world it was
one of our wide receivers and maybe
throwing a lance rental now I'm going in
the way back machine here Dan and they
didn't line up and they'd look the
referee and they'd raise their hand is
am I okay and replica kind of now you're
okay or move up
I've seen that for ever since I came to
league in 73 in the reference I move up
all of a sudden you're getting a crucial
point in a game you know he looks over
there if he's off the line well first of
all you got to know how to line up
properly so I'm gonna put some of the
onus on McClure to learn know how to
line up properly but you know sometimes
you get into the heat of the game you
look out so you want to be sure that
you're online all of a sudden you know
he gets dependently called again so at a
most inopportune time
but I'm trying to understand that that
non-verbal that you go okay am I good
and then the official I guess nut you
know kind of says you got to nudge up a
little bit move up a little bit and then
plays called he throws the flag right
away
well he was getting ready to throw the
flag before the before the ball was even
that's true yeah well here it was like
wow he's like really gonna call this you
know I mean at that time in the game
yeah I I I it was it was an infraction I
get it but I could probably show you a
tape of probably about 20 or 30 of those
every week with the guys not perfectly
lined up on the ball Bill Belichick said
after the loss against the Raiders that
uh why he didn't throw Hail Mary because
Mac Jones didn't have the arm strength
they it would have been a 55 60 yard
throw
uh Mac Jones said you know that wasn't
the case that's not the case there I'm
assuming most starting quarterbacks in
the NFL can throw the ball 60 yards
is that fair I'm going to say 65. I
would say 65. I don't think there's
probably a guy in this league that can't
heave it you know 65 yards and get it as
far as you need to get it I mean there's
some guy throwing at 75 I have an 80
those the big cannon arms and you know
those guys have a special talent
obviously we've seen historically Aaron
Rodgers thrown at 70 75 yards to win
ball games and in Hail Mary situations
that had to be one of the craziest plays
I've ever seen but do you buy that that
Belichick why wouldn't you throw a Hail
Mary
I I would I would call the Hail Mary
there but I think they actually he it
was a give up play they just don't ran
the ball in the line scrimmage and you
know it's kind of a I hope that he may
break you know 11 tackles in score which
is not going to happen uh you know it
feels up to me and I said hey let's take
it a shot let's throw the Hail Mary here
um okay is that crazy that play Then
Herm Edwards scooping up the Larry zonka
fumble
against the Giants the Eagles against
the Giants
uh probably the the the miracle of the
Meadowlands is probably more bizarre
because they did take a knee the giant
zonkey did take a knee and Franklin
master came across the line and started
a big Skirmish in the giant offensive
line got all pissed off and they say hey
let's let's run a play I want to hit the
damn they they took a kneel down they
took a kneel down the game was over so
the play before the play before they
took a knee and then there was a penalty
that's no there was a just a skirmish
yeah Joe took a knee game was over I had
thrown an interception going into the
Red Zone on a ball off Perry
Harrington's Hand by the way it was
because of course of course it was a
great drill
it was very accurate throw off his hands
and I'm sitting down the end of the
bench actually I didn't even know really
what happened until that night when I
you know got back and and watched the
news uh but they they took a knee the
game was over Franklin Master comes
started pushing and shoving you know all
sudden all the giant guys that sign
under yelling the offensive side let's
run a play I Wanna hit La Master you
know kind of like really stupid you know
so Joe knew he had gotten in trouble the
week before on another place it was a
very bizarre happening he he thought
zonko was going to get the ball Zhang
said it thought Joe was going to take a
knee and the ball you know in fact the
Manning pass the Manning uh show is
going to have a kind of a Herm on there
I think it's coming up soon I've seen
the preview it's pretty awesome
great to talk to you as always Johns
hope you're doing well and thanks for
joining us yeah doing great Dan good to
see you thank you happy holidays that's
Ron Jaworski a former NFL quarterback uh
uh went to the Super Bowl there the
Eagles pre and post game uh analyst
there for NBC Sports local in
Philadelphia